little assault on the people of ukraine
without provocation without
justification
without necessity
this is a pre-meditated attack
vladimir putin has been planning this
for months as i've been we've been
saying all along
he moved more than 175 000 troops
military equipment and positions along
the ukrainian border
he moved blood supplies into position
and built a field hospital
which tells you all you need to know
about his intentions all along
he rejected every good faith effort the
united states and our allies and
partners made to address our mutual
security concerns
through dialogue to avoid needless
conflict and avert human suffering
for weeks for weeks we have been warning
that this would happen
and now
it's unfolding largely as we predicted
in the past week we've seen shelling
increase in the donbass a region in
eastern ukraine controlled by
russian-backed separatists
russia the russian government
has perpetrated cyber attacks against
ukraine
we saw a staged political theater in
moscow outlandish in baseless claims
that ukraine was a ukraine was about to
invade
and launch a war against russia
that ukraine was prepared to use
chemical weapons the ukraine committed a
genocide
without any evidence
we saw a flagrant violation of
international law
and attempting to unilaterally create
two new so-called republics
on sovereign ukrainian territory
and at the very moment that the united
nations security council was meeting to
stand up for ukraine's sovereignty to
stave off invasion putin declared his
war
within moments moments
missile strikes began to fall on
historic cities across ukraine
then came the air raids
followed by tanks and troops rolling in
we've been transparent with the world
we've shared declassified evidence about
russia's plans and cyber attacks and
false pretexts so that there could be no
confusion or cover-up about what putin
was doing
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
today i'm authorizing additional strong
sanctions
and new limitations on what can be
exported to russia
this is going to impose severe cost on
the russian economy both immediately and
over time
we have purposefully designed these
sanctions to maximize the long-term
impact on russia and to minimize the
impact on the united states and our
allies
and i want to be clear
the united states is not doing this
alone
for months we've been building a
coalition of partners representing well
more than half the global economy
27 members of the european union
including france germany italy as well
as the united kingdom canada japan
australia new zealand and many others to
amplify the joint impact of our response
i just spoke with the g7 leaders this
morning
and we're in full and total agreement
we will limit russia's ability to do
business in dollars euros pounds and yen
to be part of the global economy
will limit their ability to do that
we're going to stunt the ability of to
finance and grow rush the russian
military
we're going to impose major and we're
going to impair their ability to compete
in high-tech 21st century economy
we've already seen the impact of our
actions on russia's currency in the
ruble
which early today hit its weakest level
ever
ever in history
the russia stock market plunged today
the russian government borrowing rates
spiked by over 15 percent
today's actions
we've now sanctioned russian banks that
together hold around one trillion
dollars in assets
we've cut off russia's largest bank a
bank that holds more than one-third of
russia's banking assets by itself
cut it off from the u.s financial system
and today we're also blocking four more
major banks
that means every asset they have in
america will be frozen
this includes vtb the second largest
bank in russia which has 250 billion
dollars in assets
as promised we're also adding the names
to the list of russian elites
and their family members
that are sanctioning that were
sanctioned as well
as i said on tuesday
these are people who personally gain
from the kremlin's policies and they
should share in the pain
we will keep up this drumbeat
of those designations against corrupt
billionaires in the days ahead
on tuesday
we stopped the russian government from
raising money from u.s or european
investors
now we're going to apply the same
restrictions to russia's largest
state-owned enterprises
companies with assets that exceed 1.4
trillion dollars
some of the most powerful impacts our
actions will come over time
as we squeeze russians access to
finances and technology
for strategic sectors of its economy and
degrade its industrial capacity for
years to come
between our actions and those of our
allies and partners we estimate that
we'll cut off more than half of russia's
high-tech imports
they'll strike a blow to their ability
to continue to modernize in the military
it'll degrade their aerospace industry
including their space program
it'll hurt their ability to build ships
reducing their ability to compete
economically
and it will be a major hit to putin's
long-term strategic ambitions
and we're preparing to do more
in addition to the economic penalties
we're imposing we're also taking steps
to defend our nato allies
particularly in the east
tomorrow
nato will convene a summit we'll be
there to bring together the leaders of
30 allied nations
and close partners to affirm our
solidarity
and to map out the next steps we will
take to further strengthen all aspects
of our nato alliance
although we provided over 650 million
dollars in defensive assistance to
ukraine just this year
this last year
let me say it again
our forces are not
and will not be engaged in the conflict
with russia in ukraine
our forces are not going to europe to
fight in ukraine but to defend our nato
allies and reassure those allies in the
east
as i made crystal clear
the united states will defend every inch
of nato territory with the full force of
american power
and the good news is
nato was more united and more determined
than ever
there is no doubt
no doubt that the united states and
every nato ally will meet our article
five commitments
which says an attack on one as an attack
on all
over the past few weeks i ordered
thousands of additional forces to
germany and poland as part of our
commitment to nato
on tuesday
in response to russia's aggressive
action including his troop presence in
belarus and the black sea i've
authorized deployment of ground and air
forces already stationed in europe to
nato's eastern flank allies estonia
latvia lithuania poland and romania
our allies
have also been stepping up
adding the other allies the rest of nato
adding their own forces and capabilities
to ensure collective defense and today
within hours of russia's unleashing its
assault
nato came together and authorized and
activated an activation of response
plans
this will enable nato's high readiness
forces to deploy
and when and where they are needed to
protect our nato allies on the eastern
boundaries of europe
and now i'm authorizing additional u.s
force capabilities to deploy to germany
as part of nato's response including
some of the us-based forces that the
department of defense placed on standby
weeks ago
i've also spoken with defense secretary
austin and chairman of joint chiefs
general milley
about preparations for additional moves
should they become necessary to protect
our nato allies
and support the greatest military
alliance in the history of the world
nato
as we respond
my administration is using the tools
every tools disposal protect american
families and businesses from rising
prices at the gas pump
you know we're taking active steps to
bring down the cost
and american oil and gas companies
should not should not exploit this
moment to hike their prices to raise
profits
you know in our sanctions package we
specifically designed to allow energy
payments to continue
we are closely monitoring energy
supplies for any disruption
we've been coordinating with major oil
producing and consuming countries toward
our common interest to secure global
energy supplies
we are actively working with countries
around the world to elevate collective
release from the strategic patrolling
reserves of major energy consuming
countries
and the united states will release
additional barrels of oil as conditions
worn
i know this is hard
and that americans are already hurting
i will do everything in my power to
limit the pain the american people are
feeling at the gas pump
this is critical to me
but this aggression cannot go unanswered
if it did the consequences for america
would be much worse
america stands up to bullies we stand up
for freedom
this is who we are
let me also repeat the warning i made
last week
if russia pursues cyber attacks against
our companies our critical
infrastructure
we are prepared to respond
for months we've been working closely
with our pride with the private sector
to harden our cyber defenses
sharpen our ability to respond to
russian cyber attacks as well
i spoke last night to president
zielinski of ukraine
and i assured him that the united states
together with our allies and partners in
europe will support the ukrainian people
as they defend their country
we'll provide you humanitarian relief to
ease their suffering
in the early days of this conflict
russia propaganda outlets will keep
trying to hide the truth and claim
success
for its military operation against a
made-up threat
but history has shown time and again
how swift gains in territory
eventually give way to grinding
occupations
acts of mass civil mass civil
disobedience
and strategic dead ends
the next few weeks and months we hard on
the people of ukraine
putin has unleashed a great pain on them
but the ukrainian people have known 30
years of independence
they've repeatedly shown that they will
not tolerate anyone
who tries to take their country
backwards
this is a dangerous moment for all of
europe
for the freedom around the world
putin has committed an assault on the
very principles that uphold the global
peace but now
the entire world sees clearly what putin
and his criminal
and and his kremlin allies are really
all about
this was never about a genuine security
concerns on their part
it was always about naked aggression
about putin's desire for empire
by any means necessary
by bullying russia's neighbors through
coercion and corruption
by changing borders by force
and ultimately by choosing a war without
a cause
putin's action betrays sinister vision
for the future of our world
one more nations take what they want by
force
but it is a vision that the united
states and freedom-loving nations
everywhere will oppose with every tool
of our considerable power
the united states and our allies and
partners will merge from this stronger
more united more determined and more
and purposeful aggression against
ukraine will end up costing russia
dearly
economically and strategically
we will make sure of that
putin will be a pariah on the
international stage
any nation the accountant as russia's
naked aggression against ukraine will be
stained by association
when the history of this area is written
putin's choice
to make a totally unjustifiable war on
ukraine will have left russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
liberty democracy human dignity these
are the forces far more powerful than
fear and oppression
they cannot be extinguished by tyrants
like putin and his armies
they cannot be erased by people from
people's hearts and hopes by any amount
of violence and intimidation
they endure
the contest between democracy and
autocracy
between sovereignty and subjugation
make no mistake
freedom will prevail
god bless the people of a free and
democratic european may god protect our
troops
[Music]
associated press zeke
do you have any plans to speak with
president putin at this point and what
interactions have you had with the
russian government
i heard the first part do i have any
plans to speak with putin at this point
and what what communications have you
had with the kremlin as far as uh
military operation ukraine and making
sure this does not spiral into a larger
conflict well it's a large conflict
already the way we're going to ensure
it's not going to aspire to a larger
conflict is by
providing all the forces needed in the
eastern european nations that are
members of nato
nato is more united than it's ever been
and i have no plans to talk with putin
[Music]
uh
wall street journal
serena
mr president you didn't mention swift in
your sanctions that you announced is
there a reason why the us uh isn't doing
that is there a disagreement among
allies um regarding swift and whether uh
russia should be allowed to be part of
it the sanctions that we've proposed on
all their banks of equal consequence
maybe more consequence than swift number
one
number two uh it is always an option but
right now that's not the position that
the rest of uh europe wishes to take
um
cecilia
cecilia
abc
sir sanctions clearly have not been
enough to deter vladimir putin to this
point what is going to stop him
how and when does this end and do you
see him trying to go beyond ukraine and
a second question i'll just give to you
now this statement that he gave last
night will that the what the threat that
he gave the west will face consequences
greater than any you have faced in
history is he threatening a nuclear
strike
i have no idea
what he's threatening i know what he has
done number one
number two
no one expected the sanctions to prevent
anything from happening it has to show
this is going to take time
and we have to show resolve so he knows
what's coming and so the people of
russia know what he's brought on them
that's what this is all about this is
going to take time it's not going to
occur he's going to say oh my god these
sanctions are coming i'm going to stand
down
he's going to test the resolve of the
west to see if we stay together and we
will we will and will impose significant
costs on him will he go beyond ukraine
sir do you see him going yes
two topics just really quick first
markets are down
and gas prices are up i know you always
stress the difference between
wall street and main street but
everybody seems to be in for some
economic pain how
economically painful is it going to get
for people in this country and i do have
one more question first of all
there's no doubt that when a major
nuclear power
attacks and invades another country that
the world is going to respond and
markets can respond all over the world
so there's no doubt about that
number one number two the notion that
this is going to last for a long time is
highly unlikely as long as we continue
to stay resolved and imposing the
sanctions we're going to impose on
russia period what's your next question
i'm sorry the next question is
did you underestimate putin and would
you still describe him the way that you
did in the summer as a worthy adversary
at the time
he was i made it clear as an adversary
and i said he was worthy i didn't
underestimate him
and i've read most of everything he's
written did you read i shouldn't i'm not
a wise guy
the you you heard the speech he made
almost an hour's worth of speech is why
he was going into ukraine he has much
larger ambitions in ukraine he wants to
in fact reestablish the former soviet
union that's what this is about and i
think that his uh
his ambitions
are are completely contrary to the place
where the rest of the world has arrived
you're confident that these devastating
sanctions
are going to be as devastating as
russian missiles and bullets and tanks
yes
russian bullets missiles and tanks in
ukraine
yes i am
[Music]
president if sanctions cannot stop
president putin what penalty can i
didn't say sanctions couldn't stop him
you've been talking about the threat of
these sanctions for several weeks now
yes but the threat of the sanctions and
imposing the sanctions and seeing the
effect of the sanctions are two
different things
for two different things and we're now
going to he's going to begin to see the
effect of the sanctions
and what will that do how will that
change his mindset here given he's
because he's so weak in his country
that he'll have to make a very very
difficult choices of whether to continue
to move toward being a second rate power
or in fact respond you said in recent
weeks that big nations cannot bluff when
it comes to something like this you
recently said the idea of personally
sanctioning president putin was on the
table is that a step that you're
prepared to take and if not a bluff is
on the table
sanctioning president putin yes why not
sanction him today sir mr president
why not sanction him
today mr president if i can you detailed
some severe and swift new sanctions
today and said the impact it will have
over time but given the full-scale
invasion given that you're not pursuing
disconnecting russia from what's called
swift the international banking system
or other sanctions at your disposal
respectfully sir what more are you
waiting for specifically with the
sanctions we've imposed exceed swift the
sanctions we oppose exceed anything
that's ever been done the sanctions we
imposed have generated two-thirds of the
world joining us they are profound
sanctions let's have a conversation in
another month or so to see if they're
working yes can i ask about zelensky sir
you spoke to vladimir zelinski yesterday
sir
what's the
what's the risk that
we are watching the beginning of another
cold war and is there now a complete
rupture in u.s and russian relations
there is a complete rupture right now in
u.s russian relations if they continue
on this path that they're on
and in terms of a cold war that depends
you have the vast majority of the rest
of the world and total opposition to
what he's doing
from asia to south america to
europe to acro around the world
and so it's going to be a cold day for
russia the idea you don't see a whole
lot of people coming to his defense
and are you are you if i could follow up
sir are you urging china to help isolate
russia are you urging china to help
isolate russia
i'm not prepared to comment on that at
the moment
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
no no no he's had his hand up a long
time thank you mr president how
concerned are you that uh putin wants to
go beyond ukraine into other countries
and the u.s will have to get involved if
he moves into nato countries well if he
did move into nato countries he will be
involved we will be involved the only
thing that i'm convinced of is if we
don't stop now he'll be emboldened
if we don't move against him now with
these significant sanctions he will be
emboldened
look
you know every uh
well anyway
can you talk anything more about your
conversation can you
[Music]
sir india which is a major defense
partner of the united states is india
with fully with you on the issue of
ukraine and russia
does the defense department of the
united states so india is one of your
major defense partners
is india fully in sync with united
states on on russia we're going to be
we're in consultation with with india
today we haven't
resolved that completely
okay thank you all very much
[Applause]
you've been listening to president biden
there taking questions announcing first
of all his reaction to the news that
president putin has